It is perhaps the most famous photograph ever
taken. It came into being almost by accident,
when on the morning of Christmas Eve 1968
one of the astronauts aboard the Apollo 8
spacecraft, Bill Anders, turned the camera
from the supposed object of their mission
– the moon – towards a spherical, brightly
glowing, blue object rising above the lunar
horizon. This was Earth, our irreplaceable
planetary home. Suddenly humankind was able
to view its habitat with a gaze hitherto reserved
for the entity we have termed God. It was
a moment that invited and continues to offer
us a fundamental change in perspective. Although
the theory that the earth was a sphere had
been proposed by ancient Greek thinkers from
Pythagoras onwards, such thinking remained
theoretical for hundreds more years, and still
remains today, as we make our way laboriously
around our streets, mountains and seas, largely
implausible. Though the Earth typically appears
inexhaustibly vast to us, suddenly it emerged
as what it truly is: just another medium-sized
planet in one solar system, in one galaxy,
in a mind-defyingly infinite universe. Though
it might seem far for an earth-dweller to
journey from NY to Sydney, or from one pole
to another, these are, in the greater scheme,
the trails of an ant. Earthrise allowed us
to feel a kind of care, even love, for the
planet. Viewed from space, we see it protected
from terrific bombardments of meteorites and
solar and cosmic rays, and made habitable,
only by an infinitesimally thin membrane – which
it is now wholly in our remit to destroy.
Our oxygen rich atmosphere – the difference
between a barren desert planet like Mars,
and our lush, abundant, breathable home – appears
in the photo as the vaguest of halos. From
up here, it is possible to feel so much more
generous towards the human project than we
normally do. We can smile gently at humanity
and perhaps admire it a little too. Everyone’s
faults drop away against such majesty. We
are tugged towards being more patient and
warm around our fellow ants spinning with
us in endless darkness. We might like to tell
one or two of these ants in franker, more
direct terms how fond we are of them. On the
planet, right now, babies are being born,
adults are crying themselves to sleep, people
are on their knees hoping for redemption.
There is struggle, error, folly and hope.
The photograph urges us towards a higher form
of kindness and forgiveness. There is – probably
– no divine being to look down on us and
help us: it’s only us responsible for ourselves
and our fragile home. We may have to adopt
in and for ourselves some of the attitudes
we once projected onto divinities. If there
were to be a new religion, one without a god,
a secular religion set up to remind us of
our need to love, to be kind and to forgive,
then Earthrise might fittingly be its logo
and its central image. But even without such
a fanciful though perhaps necessary creation,
Earthrise deserves a place on the kitchen
wall, on our screen savers and in our minds,
a constant reminder of our power, our vulnerability
and our deep responsibility to one another.
The School of Life isn't just a YouTube channel.  It's an actual school were you can go and take classes.
We have branches in ten locations around the world.  To find out more, click on the link on the screen now.